let's try to calculate 3 times 32 and i
like to rewrite it and this is one way
of doing it i like to rewrite it where i
have the larger number on top so in this
case it's 32 and i write the smaller
number right below it and since a small
number is only one digit it's only a
one's digit i put that below the ones
place on the larger number so i'll put
the three right over here and of course
we can't forget our multiplication
symbol and this is essentially a way of
saying the same thing this is you could
read this as 32 times 3 but 32 times 3
is the exact same value as 3 times 32.
it doesn't matter what order you
multiply in now let's try to compute it
and once again this is only one way of
doing it there's many ways of doing it
and i want you to think about why this
works
so we can start we'll we'll go with
we'll start with this 3 down here and
we're going to multiply it times each of
the digits in 32 so we'll start with 3
times 2.
well 3 times 2 from our multiplication
tables and you could figure it out even
if you didn't know your multiplication
tables is 6. so 3 times 2 i'll write 6
right over here in the ones place
now we're going to figure out what 3
times 3 is
well once again we know that 3 times 3
is 9 and since i'm multiplying times the
tens place right over here i'm going to
put it in the tens place right like this
so we're done we got 32 times 3 is 96
and i really encourage you to think
about why this worked and i'll give you
a little bit of a hint here i'll give
you a little bit of a hint about why
this worked remember 3 times 32 is the
same thing as 3
3 times 30
plus 3 times 2.
and if you look at it that way that's
essentially what this process did we did
3 times 2 is 6 3 times 30 is 90. you add
them together you get 90 plus 6 is 96.